if you go if you go on the Democratic
side where do I stand uh with the
Democrats absolutely when it comes to
the issue of voter protection uh and
voting in this country
um it is it is the Republican Playbook
voter suppression is no doubt the
closing of polling locations uh making
difficult I mean they've literally said
it publicly that I mean the Speaker of
the House in Georgia said if we expand
ballot drop boxes and allow folks to
vote
um uh absentee without an excuse we will
lose now my whole deal is
how can you walk around with troops and
go oh democracy and they're fighting for
our values and it's the right to vote no
every politician should want everybody
to vote
and you don't you don't create obstacles
that is the biggest one where I stand
against Republicans I don't I don't know
about that but you know what what I
would say they can break it down the
issues you know but what I would say
with that too is to you know somebody
can come back and say well Roland how
about the fact that you know Democrats
don't care about the Border because the
more people come from the border they
tend to vote more for Democrats so it's
better for them to not talk about the
borders
first of all that assumes that somebody
who's crossing the border uh is a
registered voter when they're not
because here's a deal but but the
Democrats want them to be able to vote
and to say they also have a voice should
they be able to vote but the reality is
see now what you've done is you've now
flipped it to another issue which is the
Border what I'm talking about is what is
undeniable when it comes to the no I
don't flip it no I don't flip it no no
no because
I didn't flip it I didn't flip it I
asked the question from you what
policies on the right do you agree with
what policies on the left right then I
then you brought up voting to say that
the Republicans in Georgia want to do
this then I brought up the fact I didn't
bring up border I'm bringing border to
say that those people who come across
the border many times they're going to
vote left and they're going to vote
right but see that but that's actually a
wrong assumption because I'm from Texas
and we see what actually happens is what
you have is if you're talking about
you're seeing people that come across
the border vote Republican what I'm
telling you is when you look at who is
who is coming across the border that's
fine I run an insurance company with 40
000 agents 54 Hispanic I lived in LA 24
years and here's the question no no no
but you said what you said you live in
L.A here's the fundamental problem that
people refuse to recognize when you talk
about Hispanics like Latinos in America
is Hispanic no no first of all follow me
here follow me I know exactly don't
exercise no no it's not just the Texas
side okay the problem that we have in
the country when we break down Hispanics
last Latinos and the reason I'm saying
Hispanics last Latinos is because around
the country you can't group everybody in
the same category what you have is you
might have a different different uh
philosophy if you talk about Venezuelan
keyboard in Florida compared to somebody
who is Chicano Florida
in Texas compared to Los Angeles and so
what you also have is a much different
uh Focus all you have to do is just look
up and see what percentage of Hispanic
will Democrat can you pull it out no no
what I'm saying it's about six about 65
35 64. or some places 64. so there you
go but here's the deal though if you
Republicans you liked at 35 what you
don't have for African Americans in the
case like black women who hates
Republican party the top two
constituencies for African-Americans
Democratic party are black women and
black men so you have so if you're if
you're running it's 35 40 percent it's a
damn good number oh stop it Roland this
is this this it's not you're getting 65
our vote 64 right yes what are you
talking about and if and if and if you
are and if you are a Republican or the
Republican party yeah you also have to
ask yourself what have you done to reach
a community to get them to vote for you
Hispanics yes they're increasing on the
Republicans
increasing of course yes why is it
increasing why is it increasing I'm
asking you because the policies are
helping them out no it's increasing also
because you have a party that actually
is not taking any more proactive focus
in targeting that group if you never
communicate with me yeah but never reach
out to me guess what I'm gonna go with
who normally does and so that's the
smart strategy which is what I've
actually said to Republicans for the
long is if you never talk to black
people and they never see you guess what
they ain't gonna never vote for you by
the way I don't disagree with that I
think if you want someone's vote you got
to go talk to them and what they've done
is in the last 10 years yeah especially
in the last last eight years they've
actually made a much much more concerted
effort to Target Hispanics in the United
States do you think Democrats care about
blacks more than uh Republicans do
oh absolutely really I can't let me tell
you define define care for here's the
first is the first to find care I have
to first be willing to even talk to you
Republicans by and large they want to
avoid black people a group of black
Republicans in Illinois had a meeting
with the state Republican party yeah and
they they laid out hey there are ways
that we as a party can reach out to
African-Americans in Illinois in Chicago
they finished their presentation
this is the first statement that's made
guys look we're not going to support
welfare
the black Republicans win
um
who the hell brought out welfare
it wasn't even our proposal the black
Republicans were insulted at this group
of white Republicans automatically went
to welfare
and they said
we even bring up welfare
why is that the one thing you brought up
and so what community are you talking
about what where was this at say
Illinois okay and so what I'm saying is
which you're saying Illinois Democrats
have done good for blacks in Illinois
that's not what your question was the
question was this here in terms of who
is reaching out to him right I wanted
when Mitch McConnell's book came out
right I'm on the Tom Joyner Morning Show
this is the largest black Morning Show
in the country before he retired and
we're sitting here and so I get a call
when I book a monkey no problem then all
of a sudden uh yeah uh um yeah yeah
Mitch Mitch is not going to come on the
show
okay he's discussion this book why not
this is the largest show targeting
African-Americans I can tell you I've
had open invitations to Republicans come
on the show
When Alan West was in Congress I told
him about it Alan was like are you
serious Alan tells his press secretary
Alan would show up no no he was on the
show
not not always
um because I called him on live on air
one day uh but I don't know if you're
respectful to him or not show up
anywhere no no Ali well yeah right well
not always but uh no we're with respect
he's a gamer But Not Afraid right but
not always
um
yeah he may have a schedule you're right
not all no no I caught him live on the
air uh so
um so the Amazon and I tell him that
Alan goes are you serious I said yes I
said open invitation I said to the
entire Republican caucus and he goes
tells us secretary send a note out to
the whole caucus it look you should come
on this show it's important
two and the reason other than Allen the
reason was two one uh was uh republican
from Texas a Texas A M graduate that's
why it came on the other was Pete Olson
from Texas uh who came on as well
because out of Houston and so what
happens is they avoid in many ways
talking to African Americans
you're I'm never going to be able even
to listen to you
if you don't even talk to me
and if you ever talk to me and I'm and
I've had long conversations I've known
black Republicans my entire life the
frustration they have you go back to
Jackie Robinson and Nixon in 1960. the
frustration that they have is here they
are talking about black black
conservative and being Republican and
the pushback and the hell they get from
their own I'm talking about we've had
like serious conversations and we're
talking about individuals who have been
cabinet secretaries who have been in
many layers who are millionaires who are
donors and they express how it drives
them crazy when they do it that was
Michael Williams who worked in regular
Bush breaking the Bush Administration
very good friend of mine he was gonna
have a fundraiser at his house uh and
there was a guy running for congress
against Martin Frost in Texas and he was
campaigning he brought JC Watson and
everything and at the time in these
black church burnings and so Michael
calls him up and Michael said hey
I think the candidate should release a
statement with regards to these Church
These burning black churches and they go
no no we're not going to do that that's
best pandering
like I said I'm sorry man
which I brought
Congressman JC Watson and to tour with
you to black churches
on Sunday like what the hell you call
that so Michael's wife Donna Donna said
because they were fundraiser at Michael
and Donna's house Donna said
ain't no man
who's unwilling to speak against the
burning of black churches welcome in my
house
you let them know no statement he will
not step foot in this house foreign
largely lost so that that is your uh
okay so let's say that's true no no it's
not for you it is I've been black for 54
years and I have spent as I have run
black owned media Outlets getting
Republicans to even talk to black people
show up at forums my parents work my
parents were finals of a Civic club I'm
telling you not my opinion what I've
literally experienced and what black
Republicans and even what I got
conversation about this with white
Republicans but I got to follow up for
you so in other words in other words
Democrats are only ones that had the
votes of blacks since 1964. okay 88 was
94.64 and it's now 88 86 90 right yep so
if blacks have had if if Democrats have
had that vote
since 64. that's 60 years 59 years to be
exact how come blacks haven't made major
progress if Democrats care about blacks
as much as well first of all that's
that's actually flawed question because
when you say have a major what kind of
progress
so when you look at what you're coming
out of 1960s then you go in 1970s when
you begin to see your first wave of
black Mayors across the country mayor
and bear in DC Maynard Jackson Atlanta
Coleman Young in Detroit uh of course
previously you had Gary Hatcher in Gary
Indiana which you saw for the first time
was African-Americans being able to
access uh economic a capital in this
country Maynard Jackson gets elected in
73 African-Americans were receiving
point zero zero one two percent of All
City contracts in Atlanta I didn't say
one percent I didn't say point five
percent I didn't say point one two point
zero zero one two percent of All City
contracts Maynard Jackson comes in he
says ain't gonna happen not when you
have a city that the significant number
of African Americans the reason Atlanta
is called the black Mecca today because
economically uh you're part of that
particular process when you talk about
Prince George's County being called
today uh the richest cap black County in
the country based upon home values a lot
of that is because of again Contracting
opportunities that came with mayor and
Barry uh was mayor and then coming out
of that now
what you have when you're talking about
uh the black community when you're
looking at overall you have to look at
the fact of the matter is this here
African-Americans have been technically
fully free Americans for only 53 years
53.
64 Civil Rights Act 65 Voting Rights Act
68 Fair Housing Act and you still were
dealing with
um being locked out when you look at it
look it comes the money if you if you're
not having a money conversation in
America you ain't having a real
conversation and so when you talk about
400 plus years and you're only being
technically free 53 years and you've
been locked out consistently out of
corporate America I have actually met
nipple which is sad individuals who were
the first African-Americans to ever work
at major companies and they got there in
72 73 75 78. you're like what the heck
so when you've been locked out
economically yeah which has an impact on
every single Factor place in America
housing health education then you see
why where we are today but has there
been progress yes has there been enough
progress no Roland so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast just click
right here
[Music]